it's kind of it's like the duck you know
it when you see it you know it's hard to
describe a duck but when you when you
see a duck you know it's a duck because
that's what a duck is a great conductor
is this is someone who can work with
musicians and stand in front of them and
bring out the best in them and and and
create a musical experience that
communicates to the audience and it's
hard to say what it is because there are
conductors who are very clear and showed
the tempo in a very precise way and
helped the musicians play absolutely
together but something is missing the
soul is not there the spirit is not
there and then there'll be meet
musicians or conductors who have no
obvious technique and and seem scrappy
and all over the place but something
happens so what what what it means to
conduct actually is sort of the basic
question you know the the the idea of
showing the tempo to help musicians play
together is basic but it's so much more
than that it's about inspiring them and
making the musicians feel that there's
something in the music that they want to
express and it's it's I would say it's
very hard to put your finger on what
exactly conducting is the conductor's
the person who stands in front of the
group and moves his or her arms but how
to get the musicians to be able to play
their best but also even more
importantly to want to play their best
and communicate something to the to the
audience that's all it's all part of the
equation
well it's hard to shut off the critical
faculty because what we try to do as
musicians is create the best possible
musical line and and it involves many
many choices that hopefully don't sound
like choices at the end of the day but
when I listen to a piece that I know
very well it's impossible for me to
avoid comparing it to how I feel about
the piece sometimes in the in the most
fortunate circumstances listening to a
concert I am able to forget about what I
think about how I would do the piece and
just join the join the party as it were
and just allow the music to unfold and
that generally means that I think wow
this is this at the end of the concert I
can think that was totally convincing
that was that was a beautiful
performance and that really made sense
and mute the the the depth of feeling
and the depth of meaning and the music
really came came to life there's so many
layers on which to appreciate a
performance there's the way the
interpretation goes as work we're
talking about but there's also how it's
played how much belief the the
performers have how much technical skill
they are able to bring to it you know if
their mistakes or if they're things that
don't go perfectly together I mean they
can you know things like that can happen
and you know when I listen to the New
York Philharmonic whether I'm conducting
or just listening in the audience I can
marvel at the at the at just the
technical the amazing technical level
the ability of the players to operate
their instruments that's a very exciting
level in and of itself and there's
certain pieces that are fun for that
reason almost primarily you can just
admire the way it's the way it's played
I have to say it's sometimes hard for me
to hear concerts because um a lot of the
music I you know I hear I tend to have
done myself or know and I try to leave
my preconceptions and my prejudices at
the door but it's not always possible